you know running a business could be
quite scary you could lose all your
savings you could run out of business
you can have a competitor of yours
target you want to put you out of
business you can have a partner you'll
screw you over
you take all the money you can have a
coworker of yours one of your employees
leave you take all insider information
and give it to a
competitor an enemy of yours you can
have a lot of things that can happen to
you but this week
instead of giving you a traditional
video that i'd already shot we decided
to change it up because i think it's
necessary for entrepreneurs and business
people to get perspective sometimes
last week i was at greenwich for the
entire week i had meetings from 7 am to
midnight
so i was out of pocket and i wasn't too
active on social we didn't do podcasts
we didn't do anything so
i'm at the house right now people are in
their yachts boats i sit out here and
watch the kids when they're in the back
swimming
smiling water skiing jet skiing
everybody's talking about the fight or
trades or bitcoin or crypto
or the next movie or whatever could be
there are
13 individuals families
that are mourning today who could care
less about
what's for dinner tonight
they don't care about who's fighting
they don't care about the next movie
they don't care about the next
you know latest and greatest they just
hear the fact that their loved one's not
going to be with them
they're never going to physically see
them ever again
that's painful that's real you know
it's it's have you ever had somebody a
stranger you don't know that
fought and defended for you like
defended you in a fight that happened
you didn't know this guy you didn't know
this girl
they just jumped in
now imagine if you're in a fight and
somebody pulls a knife and somebody
jumps in there in between you and the
person that's about to stab you
and they lose their lives to defend you
and you don't know this person how would
you think about that person
what if somebody did that to defend your
kid's life how would you look at that
person
what would you think of that person
see i'm putting it direct because that's
something that your i see because your
eyes seeing it is different than you're
reading about it
happening in another country thousands
of miles away from you but pretty much
what these marines and soldiers did last
week
in afghanistan
to save other people's lives
and defend our freedom because they
believe in that flag
it's pretty much the same thing
except the visual slightly different so
today
rather than giving you
the typical motivation monday video
i wanted to give you some perspective
just be grateful that you and i
have the opportunity to run a business
while there are some people
that will no longer have that
opportunity as you and i have today
we are some of the luckiest human beings
alive because other people are willing
to fight
for our freedom so a little bit of
gratitude today
is necessary so i want to spend the rest
of the time and give a
pay my respect to the following names
and soldiers
lives we lost
in afghanistan last week starting with
u.s marine joannie rosario
hunter lopez 22 years old rosario was 25
by the way
kareem nikui marine 22 years old riley
mccollum 20 years old marine
jarrod schmidt's 20 year old marine
david lee espinoza 20 year old marine
maxim soviet 20 year old
navy soldier
staff sergeant taylor hoover 31 year old
marine
deegan page 23 year old marine
ryan
23 year old army soldier
jumberto sanchez 22 year old marine
nicole g
23 year old marine
dylan merola
marine corps 20 years old
my condolences
goes out to you and your entire family
may you rest in peace i salute you
for sacrificing your life for others
although i will never
be able to personally know you
i just want you to know
to those families
my prayers goes out to you
and thank you
for these folks is
service
have a great week everybody be grateful
bye
[Music]